you know what I love it we've never done
a talk show with you but I have to say
it's great because I know I'm gonna get
really broken down afterwards kind of
like what I did moment wait is that your
door oh is that your dynamic kind of
good cop bad cop oh yeah I just have
some fearless feedback you know peerless
oh yeah June's sister can I say this
works at Apple and they say that if they
have negative comments for you it's
called fearless feedback so we give you
general out of fearless but what you
have to do when you want to give someone
fearless feedback we have will be
fearless say though before you give it
is permission for fearless feedback and
someone I have to say permission yes
please and then you deliver it yeah he
can your mission go ahead try and
fearless feedback yes I'll tell you the
only correct response to that okay a PP
yeah KC hey hey what's that man yeah
okay I'm doing pretty good okay
permission to give some fearless feed
back friendship over
so that's a fender bender every time you
say fearless feedback I feel like we all
have corporate jobs and we're in like
the backyard patio of a Marriott and our
boss is like we're gonna reinvigorate
with real estate back positive energy
get to know your cubicle mate you know I
mean did you look up your cz look under
your seat there's a handgun to end it
all we're having these conversations
because you can tell that I'm here and
I'm talking to you but I'm also looking
for a moment to be like you know what I
mean and wrap it up I didn't know that I
thought we were all having a good time
yeah get in my house that doesn't have a
fourth wall I didn't know I was trying
to hold hands to say you're doing such a
great job on your talk show and thank
you thanks for having